we are pleased to have james mccurry as
our presenter
james mccurry is a senior applications
chemist specializing in analytical
chemistry measurements for the chemical
and refining industries he is a member
of the american chemical society and the
american society of testing in the
materials
james holds abs in biochemistry from the
university of scranton and an ms and phd
in chemistry from la high university
maria gives me great pleasure to turn
today's event over to james mccurry
jim
please go ahead
i think you might be on mute gym
okay there we go
okay uh thanks madison and i'd like to
extend the welcome to all of our
attendees and express my appreciation
and taking time out of your day to
attend the webinar and hopefully we can
provide some good information for you
in terms of
intubo's capability for doing ultra fast
gc
and for those of you who are interested
in total petroleum hydrocarbon or tph
analysis
uh how this can improve your laboratory
productivity when running those methods
so i'm going to now share my
presentation
so that we can all see that
okay
so uh
the
title suggests this is looking at ultra
fast gc and in particular applying
these ultra fast
chromatography techniques to total
petroleum hydrocarbon or tph analysis
and in specific on the intubo gc system
and we see a little photograph here of
intubo
it's a a unique looking instrument as
well as a unique performing instrument
so let's take a look at what what i'm
talking about when i say total petroleum
hydrocarbon analysis
those are you who are familiar with this
environmental application
you'll know that there are many
different flavors of tph
in particular i'm going to discuss an
iso method which is iso 16703
and how we applied this method to the
ultrafast gc
techniques running on in tuvo
so first let's take a look at the the
scope of the method
and i'll put my laser pointer up here
so
uh for the scope of a method uh what it
seeks to measure are
c10 to c40 hydrocarbon contamination
that's in the environment
so this could be a number of different
types of samples specifically where this
hydrocarbon contamination comes from is
from the accumulation of what we call in
the energy and chemical industry middle
distillates
and lubricating oils middle distillates
being things like diesel fuel jet fuel
home heating oil and so forth
these get into the environment by spills
leakage
from delivery mechanisms such as
pipelines and trucks
and
also just from
say
spills coming from ships
now the contamination can exist in
different types of environmental samples
water soil and sediment the iso 16 703
method
addresses specifically soil and
sediments there are other
international
and u.s methods that do address
water
matrices for this
analysis the concentration range covered
by the scope is between 100 milligrams
per kilogram and 10 000 milligrams per
kilogram and that's in the sample itself
so in the soil or sediment
specific to iso 16703
what's unique about this method is we
don't actually measure individual
hydrocarbons but we measure the entire
hydrocarbon load that can be found in
these environmental samples
therefore speciation or separation of
individual
compounds is not really necessary we're
really just
getting them through the gc basically as
a broad aleutian profile
and then measuring that broad illusion
profile without really any regard to
individual compounds
but although that's not entirely true we
do need to see two of the marker peaks
and we'll see that uh in later slides
the c10 and c40 which
denotes
where the aleutian profile
for quantification exists
so for this method for the sample
analysis
first there's a relatively rigorous and
complex sample preparation
that is multi-step and this is used to
extract the hydrocarbons from the matrix
but when you do the extraction a lot of
other things from the environmental
samples will come along
and we want to eliminate those so there
are some several steps that seek to
clean up as much of the environmental
matrix as possible and leave behind only
the hydrocarbon
contamination that we're trying to
measure
once the sample is prepared
they're then now analyzed with gas
chromatography
by running the extracts through a gc
column with detection by a flame
ionization detector or fid
if we look at this method some of you
who are maybe familiar with
simulated distillation or simdisc
methods
this method looks very similar to that
and in fact some of the astm simdisc
methods actually seek to measure
the same range of hydrocarbons
and
actual fuel samples as we are measuring
here
in the fuel once it's contaminated in
the environment so there's a lot of
overlap and similarities between
at the jews in the industry for
energy production and then also in
environmental laboratories
typically what we'll be using is a high
temperature gc so we want to go from
roughly ambient conditions a little bit
above ambient 40 degrees centigrade and
then program the gc column up to 350
degrees
and we'll be doing this with a fast
temperature program ramp as we'll see in
later slides as i mentioned
previously the only two peaks that we
really need to identify are the c10 and
c40 these are retention time markers
that are actually spiked into the sample
and these denote the start of the
aleutian profile of the hydrocarbons and
the end of the aleutian profile the
hydrocarbons
that are included in the scope of iso
16703
a key to the performance of this method
is reducing uh boiling point
discrimination particularly for
the high level and low level
boiling contaminants or boiling
components that are in the extracted
hydrocarbons
if we don't eliminate discrimination
this will
cause a failure to achieve accurate
quantification
by discrimination what i'm talking about
here is inlet discrimination so with
improper injection technique you may
actually lose some of the low or high
boiler components they're not
transferred
effectively from the inlet to the column
and thus we will skew the
quantification of the sample so there
are a number of tests that we have to
meet to demonstrate uh reduction of
boiling point discrimination and i'll
show how we meet those
okay so
uh tph uh using ultra-fast gas
chromatography and i've abbreviated that
by ufgc
uh
is shown here so
the fact that we are not doing compound
speciation or trying to separate all the
compounds
is
an ideal situation for trying to apply a
method to ultra fast gc because we don't
really have to worry about
chromatographic resolution
so with ultra fast gc the definition of
that is typically its analysis times in
the one to three minute range and the
way that we achieve this is with rapid
column heating so typically we'll ramp
the oven temperature for the gc column
at 100 degrees per minute or higher over
the entire temperature program range so
for
this particular method it'll be from 40
to 350 degrees
another technique for ultra fast dc is
employing short
narrow columns
typically in the three to five meter
range whereas most of us who use gc
columns will be using them somewhere
between say 15 and 30 or 60 meters
this is quite a short column and shorter
columns of course produce faster
analysis time but it does that at the
expense of chromatographic resolution
but as i said for this method we're not
seeking chromatographic resolution we
just need to get that that profile or
that envelope of hydrocarbons
through the column as quickly as
possible
then finally the third technique that's
defines ultrafast gc
are using higher carrier flow rates uh
typically we'll go greater than five
mils a minute for those most narrow bore
columns we're usually running column
flow rates from about half a millimeter
to
maybe two or three mills a minute so we
go quite a bit faster when using ultra
fast gc techniques
some of the challenges that are uh
presented to us when trying to do ultra
fast gc is first of all retention time
precision
and
what we're trying to do here is make
sure that the retention times don't
drift
and
when we're ramping the oven very quickly
and using
high constant flow rates there's an
interaction between the
column ramping temperature
and the control of the pressure and
that's flow through the column that has
to be consistent from run to run
otherwise you won't get good retention
time precision if you don't have good
retention time precision
then trying to
integrate the
envelope of the compounds that are
eluding and identify the marker peaks
can become very difficult
so with ultrafast gc you need a
good interaction between very precise
column temperature
control and very precise flow control
while you're rapidly heating that column
another challenge for ultra fast gc
particularly for this method is column
lifetime
since we're going up to 350 degrees uh
that rapid heating and that higher
temperature that's being applied to the
column
can cause the columns of the grade
there's several different modes of
degradation that can happen
first
if you're using
columns that have a direct heating
element
wound with them
one of the examples of this is
there are low thermal mass columns
rapid
column heating and then cooling
to high temperatures can affect some of
the heating elements there and cause
failure one of the primary modes of
failure is the polyamide coating on the
column
these columns are glass but they have a
polymer coating that makes them flexible
so that when they're bent the glass
doesn't break this polyamide coating
though is not totally in there to the
atmosphere and it can break down so when
we're rapidly heating the high
temperatures the polyamide coating will
eventually oxidize over time and as it
oxidizes it will expose the glass and
that can cause column breakage
then finally the last mode of column
failure with ultra fast gc is a
stationary phase typically we're going
to be using thinner film stationary
phases again to reduce
the retention time or the hold time for
the later alluding peaks
and with thinner stationary phases they
will degrade faster when we're rapidly
heating to high temperature so all these
things need to be taken into account
when
looking for a gc system to do
these high temperature ultra fast
techniques
okay so let's take a look at the intuvo
and some of the features of intuba
they're specifically designed to do
ultra-fast gc
so within tuvo we have a new column
heating technology we don't have a
column in an air bath oven that we're
typically used to we have a unique
approach to column heating
and this is a direct column heating pad
and i'll show a photograph of that in a
moment
that applies the heat directly to the
column it doesn't heat the air around
the column it heats the column directly
what this allows us to do is to rapidly
heat the column and in this case we can
go up to 250 degrees per minute over the
entire temperature programming range of
the oven and that's 40 to 450 degrees
because we're not
having a complex wrapping of a heating
element and temperature sensing around
the column
it's more of a direct heating of the
instrument to the column there are fewer
elements to fail so
this will ensure better lifetime of the
columns as we run more and more samples
the next feature of intuvo that allows
ultra fast gc techniques is the next
generation
epc or electronic pneumatic control
this is a
new generation i think it's our sixth
generation of column epc
and this
works in conjunction with the rapid
heating of the column
to deliver the precise constant carrier
flows that we need to do the fast gc
as we're heating the column to very high
temperatures
what this will do is the
working of these two elements the column
heater and the epc
to give us precise flow and precise
heating that will ensure that the
retention times are consistent as well
as give us more stable detector response
so let's take a look at in tuvo now i'm
not intubal has a lot of
new and novel gc features to it
i'm not really going to discuss all
those today
we just have
some of the
benefits are shown here first of all
it's easier to use installing columns
and maintenance is much easier it's
faster this is the
main point that i'm going to be focusing
for ultra-fast gc is the speed
it's also as you can see it's a smaller
gc so you can pack more of them into a
laboratory space than with a
conventional
air bath oven gc
then also it's smarter it has a lot of
built-in intelligence and with the
introduction last year of agilent's 8890
and 8860 gc
we've improved the
smart capabilities of that platform and
have taken those
new features in terms of smart gc and
put them back into intuvo so brought in
tuvo up to the current level of gc
and then also we say it's greener
it uses a lot less energy because we're
not heating a big air bath oven we're
only heating the specific elements
that allow us to do gas chromatography
so let's take a look at the inside of
intubo so when you open the door
uh there's actually two doors this is
the main door here we've taken off here
the column oven door and we're going to
just focus here on the column of our
direct heating element
you can see that the column if we look
over here at the column it's in a
different format than we're used to
seeing it's not wound on a cage it's
actually wound in a planar format
because it's now all the coil
wrappings of the column are in one plane
we can press that against this heating
element and behind here it looks like a
mirror but that's actually our direct
heating element and then when we close
the door of this a pad will go over the
column push it into the heating element
and eliminate all the air space there so
that the heat is directly applied to the
column not to the air around it
when the run is over the heating pad
moves away and there's a separate fan
down here at the bottom that will blow
ambient air across the column and the
heating pad or the heating element to
cool it down very rapidly so not only
does it heat up fast but it also cools
faster than a typical air bath oven so
this and the new generation epcs is
what's going to allow us to do these
ultra fast gc techniques
here again we can see a closer view
of the heating element so you can see
this looks like a mirror behind here but
it is actually
a planar thin heating element that the
column is pressed against
and then the column is connected up here
to the flow path to our inlet and
detector
okay so let's look at the specific way
we're going to apply
agilent's intubo
ultrafast
capabilities to making the
tph method according to iso 16703
faster
so
we're not going to be using the
instrument conditions specifically
outlined in the iso methodology and
that's because it is geared towards an
air bath oven and we're going to be
using ultra fast gc so we're going to be
using a shorter
thinner film column than what's in the
iso method we're also going to be using
higher flows and also
faster temperature program ramps in
order to get this analysis done faster
the other parts of the method in terms
of the hardware will be the same we're
still going to be injecting the sample
onto the column
with a split splitless inlet and we're
going to be detecting using a standard
flame ionization detector
now in order to test our method uh i'm
going to actually run real samples and
the samples that i obtained come from
this organization here i'm not going to
butcher the pronunciation of it because
i don't speak german but it is shortened
into the acronym bam
so we bought certified reference uh
samples from bam these are real world
samples so this is real river sediment
and real soil that has been known to be
contaminated with
the
tph range
oils or fuels
these
river and soil samples
were then
divided up and sent to a number of
different laboratories
those laboratories use the iso 16703
method to measure the tph and so they
have what is called a consensus value so
all that data is pulled together so we
have an idea of what the contamination
level is
in each of the samples and what the
precision
obtained by all those laboratories
was for running these samples
the way we're going to do this
we're going to
take these samples and we're going to
prepare them multiple times using the
sample prep protocol outlined in the iso
method so the steps are shown here so
we're doing ultrasonic liquid solid
extraction
with an acetone and heptane
solvent
then we're going to
decant off the
extraction liquid and we're going to
centrifuge that to remove the fine
particles
then we're going to do a liquid liquid
extraction cleanup to remove the acetone
this will be using water with a
separatory funnel
and then finally we're going to be using
a solid phase extraction or spe final
cleanup what this cleanup does is
removes all of the naturally occurring
organic material that's in the soil and
river sediment samples
that comes through the extraction
process and so this will eliminate a lot
of the background contamination and then
just leave behind the hydrocarbons that
we're seeking to measure from these
samples
so in this case we're following exactly
the iso
16703 protocol for sample prep
for the gc part of it using the intuvo
gc
we're going to be doing a 5.5 microliter
injection
a split split less inlet in the split
list mode
this is important the focus liner that
we're using is
one of the key elements to try to get
the
the best
performance in terms of
inlet discrimination so this will really
help to vaporize the wide boiling range
of the sample
uh very quickly and then transfer that
in a representative fashion from the
inlet onto the column
and the inlet temperature is going to be
350 degrees
now tuvo has two other
heated elements here that we need to be
aware of
there's the guard chip the guard chip is
a device that's in between the inlet and
the column
that can be used to trap any
heavy sample matrix from getting onto
the column
but because we've done this
really
very exacting and rigorous sample prep
we're not really going to be
doing to we're transferring too much
nonpolar or high boiling matrix to the
column but we do have to be aware that
the guard chip is there as a protective
device for
uh keeping the column uh operating
correctly so the
uh this has a separate temperature uh
control and so we're going to put this
in what's called track oven mode so it
will start at about 50 degrees above our
starting temperature for the column oven
and then it will track the column oven
and when it column oven reaches its
maximum temperature the guard chip will
come
to its temperature
as well
there's also what's called the bus
temperature this is just the flow path
that the column takes between
the guard chip and the column and then
from the end of the column to the
detector and again we're going to leave
this at 350 degrees which is
similar to the split splitless inlet the
column we're using is a high temperature
column it's a db1 ht
i said we're going to be using a shorter
column so 5 meters
0.32 millimeter id with a thin film 0.1
millimeter
uh
film thickness
and for doing high boiling components
0.1 thinner film columns like a 0.1
millimeter allows those high boiling
components to elute out of the column
faster as i said we're truly trying to
improve the speed here
and towards that we're using our helium
carrier gas at 10 mils a minute constant
flow and here's our oven temperature
program so we're starting at 40 degrees
centigrade holding that for about a half
a minute this will allow transfer of the
heptane solvent and then all the
components from the inlet and give us a
little bit of solid focusing and then
we're going to rapidly ramp up uh at 250
degrees a minute the maximum ramp rate
for intubo to 350 degrees a minute to
very quickly get that hydrocarbon
profile
through the column and into the detector
and that will hold for half a minute and
finally the fid temperature is held at
350.
so let's take a look at some data now so
the first thing we did when we were
testing this method within tuvo is we
wanted to make sure that the um
the column performance was good over a
long period of time
because we're doing really ultra fast gc
this will allow laboratories to run a
lot more samples in a given workday
and so we want to make sure that with
that large number of samples that are
being run
the conditions or the performance of the
system isn't changing in a short period
of time with the large number of samples
that are run
so this is a performance test mix
for the ultra fast gc
tph method here we see our c10 to c40
peaks with some other peaks in between
here
you can see now the runtime that c40 is
eluding in less than two minutes
it looks like the the c10 elutes just
under one minute
and what we're looking at here is a
agreement between the first injection
and injection number fifteen hundred and
you can see that the retention times
really haven't shifted very much they've
gotten a little bit shorter but not
significantly shorter also you can see
the peak shape is maintained so
although we're losing some stationary
phase because the phase will bleed off
over time
we're not really losing so much that
it's affecting the peak shape we're just
getting a little bit shorter retention
time
and
for various systems that we've tested
we've gone up to 3000 injections before
the column needed to be changed
so let's look at the inlet
discrimination test this is an important
test you have to meet the
16703 requirements before you can really
run any samples
so you can purchase a
a performance test mix for
discrimination this contains
hydrocarbons in a heptane solvent from
c10 to c40 and we're going every two
column or carbon numbers so c10 c12 etc
all the way up to c40 now according to
the method
you look at your c20 peak and that
becomes your reference so that has a
defined recovery of
one
and then you look at the c40 peak and
you ratio the area between the c40 and
the c20
and
that ratio has to be greater than 0.8
and you can see here for this method
or for this
run we're getting 0.93 so this is
essentially telling us that we're not
losing any of the higher boiling or
lower blowing components
during the injection period because you
can see here the c10 recovery is 0.98 we
pretty much stay almost 1 all the way up
to c36
c38
and then c40 is 0.93
which is well within the
range specified by the method
i also want to take a look at
the calibration
performance so the method requires you
to run the middle standard so peak num
standard number three you run it three
times and then you look at the total
area of the
aleutian profile of the hydrocarbons so
here's our c-10 peak and our c-40 peak
we set our integrator to sum all the
area at the end of the aleutian of the
c10 and the beginning evolution of the
c40 and we just look at that total area
under this profile
and we do that three times we get the
average
and then the standard deviation and the
relative standard deviation
and according to the method the rsd has
to be less than five percent rsd
you can see here we're less than two
percent rsd
so this is telling us that we've met the
discrimination test we're meeting the
calibration test
and then finally you have to look at the
calibration curve itself
and you need to have at least a 0.99
correlation coefficient and here we have
a six level calibration
and our correlation coefficient is
essentially almost five four nines
so we're meeting that test as well
okay so let's look at a real sample
that's being run here so as i said i
took uh the two samples and extracted
them
multiple times and then
we'll do multiple injections of those
samples but let's take a look at one of
them so this is the soil sample so this
is our bam uo21 this is a
soil sample that's been certified to
have a mineral oil contamination in it
so this is the actual run so here's our
heptane solvent front
we can easily separate our c10 marker
from the solvent front
and then our final marker or c that
should be c40 sorry
that's a typo so uh
we integrate between the c10 and the c40
and we also want to make sure that our
retention times are the same
so let's take a look at another extract
that i did of the same material and
overlay that now you can see that this
chromatogram is if blue
and when i do the overlay i'll color
that chromatogram in
red
and as we all know if we mix red and
blue we get purple so let's take a look
at
how good the overlap is between our two
sample preps run on a tubo so we'll move
that on here
and you can see that we get near perfect
overlay of the two samples two
separately prepared samples
run on
two different runs you can see now the
chromatogram looks purple so it gives us
a idea that there's a near perfect
overlay both in retention time
and in peak
intensity so we're getting exceptionally
good
precision on our retention times
and also we're not getting any inlet
discrimination or removal of the higher
boiling components
let's take a look at the same sample
this is 10 different sample preps that
were run
and we're looking now overall the
retention time stability
and you can see here i focus on
the
c10 peak which is our first marker and
the c40 peak which is our second marker
so i zoomed in on those and you can see
the range here of the retention times so
for the c10 is 0.751 to 0.754
so that's ex extremely precise retention
time precision and again for the higher
boiling components it's even better
we're only .001 minutes difference
between the high and the lows of these
10 overlaps so we get
rsds for retention time precision that
are much less than one for the c10 and
much less than 0.1 for the c40
okay so these are two
of the samples that we ran so just
showing example chromatograms so in the
upper one we've we've seen this before
this is the uh the mineral oil sample in
the
soil
that's extracted from the soil and this
is the mineral oil contamination in the
river sediment river sediment is quite a
bit more challenging because as you can
imagine there's
more of a
natural
organic load in there so
when you extract this and clean it up it
looks like a much dirtier sample and
that's very important to use the the
solid phase extraction cleanup at the
end to eliminate all that
then finally let's take a look at the
quantitative results so as i said
i prepared each one of the samples
twice ran them
five times each for a total of 10 runs
so this is the soil sample this is the
river sediment sample
and so we can see uh what intubal is
going to deliver is method accuracy
so look at the mean here for our
two samples that i prepared so i have 3
500 milligrams per kilogram on sample on
the sample prep 1
and 3484
for sample prep 2 of the soil sample and
the certified value the consensus value
that bam has published with the method
is 3560 plus or minus 260. so you can
see that we have near perfect agreement
within 2-0
running the ultra-fast method
uh compared to laboratories running the
standard iso 16703 method which is about
a 30 or 35-minute run time
again if we look at
excuse me the river sediment samples
these are a little more challenging of
course because they have a higher matrix
load a lot more cleanup that has to be
done
you can see again our two sample preps
and our five runs of each one of those
and we have uh a measured value of eight
seven zero nine milligrams per kilogram
and eight six four seven
and again you can see that is near
perfect agreement with the certified
value of 8270 plus or minus 550.
so we're getting very good accuracy
we're really agreeing with those
laboratories that are running the
standard slower
iso method for tph
we also look at the instrument precision
so if we just look at the rsds for these
results you see that the rsds for all of
them are less than one percent
and so this shows very high instrument
precision but we also want to look at
the method precision so the method
precision
includes not only the instrumental
analysis but also the sample prep
so
the way the instrument or the method
precision is defined as reproducibility
so
small r
and the way that you do this is you
measure the difference between two
identical analyses of the same sample
and that difference has to be less than
what's published in the method
so for the soil sample the difference
between two sequential analyses has to
be less than 136 milligrams per kilogram
if you see here our difference on
average is about 60
uh milligrams per
kilogram
so this again showing very high method
precision for the soil sample the
difference between two
identical analyses
of the same sample
is should be less than 337 milligrams
per kilogram and we're measuring 126. so
not only are we getting good instrument
precision but the method precision is
also extremely high
so in summary
we're able to develop an ultra fast
gc method
that completes a total petroleum
hydrocarbon sample run in three minutes
as opposed to 30 or 35 minutes and we do
that by using shorter columns and take
advantage of the intubo fast oven
programming
with the sixth generation epc to deliver
precise hydrogen carrier constant flow
rates
the
intubogc has its direct column heating
and the sixth generation epc so that's
what makes this possible
and because of this there's no need to
do any post-run
lineup manipulation of the data
some
[Music]
instrument vendors will do that they're
not getting good retention time
precision so they'll use
chemometric techniques to then adjust
that retention time there's no need to
do that we naturally and organically get
extremely good retention time precision
with our direct column heating and our
pneumatics
column of column flow control
so this ultra fast gc method it meets
all of the iso performance benchmarks
for selectivity resolution
discrimination and calibration
so we've shown that the quality
quantitative results for the certified
reference materials
show extremely good agreement with other
laboratories running the slower
version of the iso method
and then we also have
extremely good repeatability compared to
what we'll typically find with the
published iso 16 703 method
so for the value proposition for what
intubo can bring to your laboratory
using ultrafast gc is lower cost of
ownership and return on investment you
can improve your laboratory
throughput
up to a factor of 10 or even higher
we get greater column lifetime
the guard chip will replace a retention
gap and protect the column from
matrix contamination and then also
it's a simpler column format and there's
less degradation
less complexity to the column when doing
this rapid heating over and over again
to high temperatures so the columns
should last longer
using an ultra fast gc method within
tuvo
ease of use
because of the high throughput of this
laboratories are typically used to
changing the columns fairly often the
columns will degrade over time mostly
related to the stationary phase
degradation
and within tuvo i didn't really go into
it but some of our other webinar series
will
it's easier and faster to change the
columns especially compared to something
like ltm
or our low thermal mass columns there's
no complex unions or connections to make
and the guard chip is easy to change and
that eliminates retention gap
trimming so for further information for
this particular application
we do have an application note that's
published this is the document number so
if you go to agilent's website type this
document number into the search field
you'll get a pdf of the
the application there
so that concludes today's webinar on
showing how intubo
can
be a financial and a
technological
improvement to your laboratory
specifically using its capability for
ultra-fast gc
and i'd like to turn it back over to our
audience to see if there's any
questions all righty wonderful thank you
so much jim for that wonderful
presentation
so before we go to our q a session i
just want to open up our short polling
survey
concerning today's presentation
while this poll is optional we do
appreciate you taking the time to answer
each question because it helps us with
modifications
for our future into a webinar
that poll is now open on the lower right
side of your console we thank you for
completing this survey
all right and on to our q a session
concerning today's presentation you may
ask questions at any time by placing
them in the question box located on your
webex platform
if you would like to ask a question over
the phone line please click the raise
hand icon located on the bottom right of
your webex
i will receive this notification and
unmute your line
where you will let me ask you a question
alrighty so our first question
so we have noticed with the fast rapid
heating and cooling of our intubo gcs
the temperature sensors for the guard
chip and detector seem to fault after a
couple of months of use
is there any development on improving
the sensors to handle the higher
temperatures
yeah i know that with the first
generation
of ventuvo
particularly if we're running high
temperatures there there have been some
decoupling of the heater element from
the guard chip heater
those have been redesigned and there was
a service note that was put out and so
those can be upgraded
and
the other thing you want to make sure
is that you
don't heat the guard chip more than
necessary
in this case i was using for this
analysis the
oven track mode so it stayed at its high
temperature for a relatively short
period of time
and that worked perfectly well for this
analysis
some customers uh
think that or will suspect that
hotter is better and that's not always
necessarily the case
so um
you want to make sure that
you don't heat it
first to too high of a temperature for
too long over a period of time also when
the instrument is idle you probably want
to have a idle mode or an idle method
that has that at a lower temperature and
leaving it at say 150 degrees is
perfectly fine
that will
avoid buildup of any contamination say
from your carrier gas or
from any septum
bleed that may
work its way through
wonderful thank you
uh next question
why did you choose helium as the carrier
gas
why not h2 or n2 considering helium
stored it
shortages and most tph methods are ran
by environmental labs
which are all about cost saving measures
right so that's uh
when
when we did this application in 2016
there wasn't as
the supply and the cost of helium had
come down from
previous problems that had happened
several years before that and in the
subsequent time uh
the
shortage and expense of helium has
gotten
worse again so that's something that we
definitely want to go back and take a
look at now based on other experience
with converting methods from helium to
hydrogen this would be actually a fairly
easy conversion um
what we could do is uh just leave the um
the hold up time or the linear velocity
the same as the helium and in that way
we won't get any difference in retention
time so it'll all be roughly the same
just with the hydrogen carrier gas
there may be actually
a way to do a little bit of speed
improvement again with hydrogen
nitrogen
i didn't really think about that as you
go to higher temperatures with nitrogen
it's it's a more viscous gas
and it requires higher pressures to push
that through a narrow column
our epcs for capillary gc
although they can use nitrogen they
really can't deliver the high pressures
that are always necessary
for higher flow rates at high
temperature and so i didn't really
consider nitrogen for that
but hydrogen you make a good point
hydrogen is something that should
definitely be tried uh especially these
days
and i think it would be a fairly uh fast
and easy way to do that and that's
something that we should take a look at
going forward
perfect thank you
our next question
can the intuo be used to run texas
1
1005. it uses carbon ranges of c6 to c12
greater than c12 to c28 and
greater than c28 to c35
uh yeah entugo could certainly be used
to do that but not with this method
as you saw
now we're using in this method we're
extracting our
samples with heptane
and in the texas method which is used by
a number of different states
we nee as you as you pointed out we need
to go down to c6 so that heptane
wouldn't be an appropriate solvent
typically something like
methylene chloride or
pentane is used
but trying to apply that
those looking at those lower carbon
numbers using this ultra fast method
particularly this particular ultra-fast
method we looked at it and it definitely
does not work
there's not enough
ability to separate the solvent from
from the lower boiling components
with this particular column
now one could use a longer slightly
thicker film column and i know some of
our colleagues in europe have done that
and that seems to work pretty well so
you don't get the
less than three minute run times they're
a little longer and i know they've used
say a 15 meter column with a
say a 0.25 micron film thickness
and they've gotten good separation and
good
retention time stability with the c6 to
c12 carbon range
and so
that would have to be a a separate
method
for the higher boiling
portions of the texas method uh it
probably could this this technique or
what i described here today could
probably be used or maybe
some
adjustment
in the ramp rate that would have to be
done
to
get good separation but
this is really
geared towards the middle distillates
the the c10 the c40 range
a separate method would have to be
developed for other ranges
okay perfect
next question how does the intubal liner
used in this method compare with the
multi-mode inlet for conventional gc
methods
well when we did this
the multi-mode inlet is a temperature
programmable inlet and that's not really
necessary for this method
so that is a thinner body
split split less type method or type
inlet that
also has a cooling coil on it so within
tuvo you can run
air through it to rapidly cool it
uh i have run this method at the request
of some of our european customers using
the multi-mode inlet and it worked just
fine so there really wasn't
any significant difference between using
that and the split split list although i
didn't really take advantage of the
temperature programmability
of the multi-mode inlet
so
really i
it's more expensive inlet so i don't
know what it would get you other than
more flexibility so if you wanted to use
this intubo for other things where
temperature programming the inlet
was required
then that would give you more
flexibility and you could run this
method on that just leaving the inlet
temperature at 350 degrees like we did
with the split split list
perfect see
another question does the intubo have an
optional h2 sensor so shut down the gc
if a leak is greater than one or two
percent
uh no it does not but you have to
remember the intubo does not have an air
bath oven uh like our conventional gcs
so there isn't a big open void inside
where hydrogen can collect
and so you really would never be able to
build up the hydrogen uh to the level
where it would reach the lower explosive
limit in addition to that in tuvo has i
think
four or five internal fans that are
constantly moving air through the intuvo
and so there isn't really any way that
hydrogen could be built up
now given that you
the intubo does have
in the epc the safety features that all
of our other inlet epcs have so there's
a limiting frit built into the epc so
it caps off the amount of carrier gas
and if you're using hydrogen the amount
of carrier gas that we get through the
epc into the inlet
so that caps that off in addition to
that
there are pressure and flow sensors so
if there's a breakage anywhere in the
flow path
that would be sensed by the epc and the
instrument would go through a shutdown
mode so everything would be cool off
the epc would be turned off and
it would stop the flow of the carrier
gas
the hydrogen into the inlet so that
safety feature is inherent into all our
epcs
but there really is no place to put a
hydrogen sensor and there's really no
as i said
air voids inside the instrument where
hydrogen could possibly build up
perfect okay thank you john
all right so i don't see any other
questions in my chat or q a blog
at this point i'll go ahead and take
over um jim there might have been some
questions that may have been delivered
to your chat or q a box so if you want
to check i'm going to go over a couple
of points
before we start closing out please note
that this is an ongoing series of rntwo
webinars
they do run monthly
so you can see our next four months
listed in the slide currently displayed
jim does come back in september
and then
this is going to be the url where i post
all of the recordings i'll post today's
recording here
as well as emailing it to everyone so
usually within 24 to 48 hours i will
send out the recording i'll send out
links to register for next events
so be on the lookout for that in your
inbox in the next day or two i have also
included
jim's email address here in case you
would like to ask him questions directly
or have any follow-up or feedback
of the source for any questions he
answered today
but jim is there anything else that you
would like to go over any questions that
may have gotten delivered to you
that we had not discussed yet
no but i really appreciate all of our
participants
and especially the really good questions
that were
were asked
i think this
shows that there is a real interest in
tuvo
in general and in running
faster tph analyses
in specifically so
i do plan to look at some of the the
water methods for tph running on intubo
as soon as
our covet 19 restrictions are listed and
i can get back to the laboratory so we
should see some more
uh information about tph type analyses
on this platform
thank you jim
all right everyone so it appears we've
reached the conclusion of our event so
please join me in thanking jim mccurry
for his wonderful presentation
i will leave the session open for a few
minutes to receive any feedback or
additional questions
but we are now going to close the audio
line
thank you all once again for attending
and on behalf of azure technologies we
wish you all a great day